morning. Exodus 17 1 through 7. All the congregation of the people of Israel moved on from the wilderness of sin by
stages according to the commandment of the Lord and camped at Refidem that there was no water for the people to drink.
Therefore the people quarreled with Moses and said give us water to drink and Moses said to them why do you quarrel with me?
Why do you test the Lord? But the people thirsted there for water and the people grumbled against Moses and said why do you bring us up?
Why did you bring us up out of Egypt to kill us and our children and our livestock with thirst?
So Moses cried to the Lord what shall I do with this people? They are almost ready to stone me.
And the Lord said to Moses pass on before the people taking with you some of the elders of Israel and take in your hand the staff with which you
struck the Nile and go. Behold I will stand before you there on the rock of Horab and you shall strike the rock and water shall come out of it and the people will drink.
And Moses did so in the sight of the elders of Israel and he called the name of the place Masha and Meribah because of the quarreling of the people of Israel and because they tested the Lord by saying is the Lord among us or not.
This is the word of the Lord.
May the Lord open our eyes that we might behold wondrous things in his word.
One of the wonderful things about living in Alabama is all the different town names on if you've ever been traveling and come across some unusual town names.
I mean as you're driving down the road you might come across a possum trot or the metropolitan place called Scratch Ankle.
There's another place called Lick Skillet which is apparently named after a fight that broke out in the town where somebody got licked and hit with a skillet and took him out.
Our journey through the wilderness has taken us to a point where we have reached a place with some, not just one unusual names but two unusual names.
And we read about that down there in verse 7.
It's the place that's now called Masha and Meribah or Meribah.
I don't really know how to pronounce those properly but that's what they are.
So Meribah and Masha.
What are these places about?
Well these two names really give us touch points for telling us about what happened there in this place which we read about in Exodus chapter 17.
So what I want us to do for the next few moments is to take these place names.
You've got two names for the same place and we're going to walk through those as kind of touch points to tell us about what happened there.
But then we'll land on one more word which really summarizes what we're seeing here in Exodus 17.
So first of all let's look at this place Meribah.
In verse 1 we see that the congregation went to the place they've left the wilderness of sin by stages according to the commandment of the Lord.
And they camped at Refidim.
So Refidim, what is this place?
Well Refidim means rest.
It's a place of rest and yet when we come there we see that it's now called after what took place Meribah which means something very different.
Meribah means to quarrel.
So how did it get that name?
What happened here for it to be called quarreling?
Well when they got there the people could not find any water.
We've seen this before and we're going to see it again.
So they can't find anything to drink and they've been in this situation before.
They've seen God provide in some amazing ways.
So how did they respond when they can't find any water to drink?
Do they pray?
Do they remind one another of God's promises?
Do they have a time where they give testimonies of God's faithfulness in the past?
No, they grumble once again.
This is the fourth grumbling account we've now come to in the book of Exodus.
But I want you to notice there's something different about this account to the
grumbling accounts that came before.
The grumbling is now turned up a notch to quarreling.
You come to verse two.
It says the people quarreled with Moses and it said give us water to drink.
Again Moses said to them why do you quarrel with me?
And then at the end it was called Merah but because there they quarreled.
It sounds like some of our family road trips, I don't know if any of yours have gone that way.
It's a word that's often used in Scripture for arguments that take place.
But sometimes the word is even used for getting into physical altercations,
like actual fighting.
And we see both of those things here.
You see them speaking with hostility and how they speak to Moses and when Moses cries out to God,
he's worried they're not just going to speak to him in this way.
He's afraid they're actually going to stone him.
You see that in verse four.
So this could have been a place of rest for them if they trusted in the Lord but instead it
became this place of quarreling.
So why have they responded in this way?
Well if we were to ask the Israelites at this precise moment like why are you responding in this way?
They might look at us with a crazed look in their eye and say because we're thirsty.
They might have even had a rock in their hand by now.
What do you mean?
Why are we quarreling?
There's no water to drink.
Thankfully we can take a step back from the heat of the moment and ask that question
in light of the rest of Scripture.
Why are they quarreling?
Well actually Scripture has a lot to say about quarreling and conflict.
And it goes right the way back to the Garden of Eden.
You know Adam and Eve knew peace with God and peace with one another.
But instead of trusting in God's goodness and following his commands, they disobeyed.
What was the result of their disobedience?
We have this disruption in their relationship with God and even with their relationship with each
other. So sin affected their relationship, separation from God and this disunity with
one another as well.
You see the brokenness that sin brought into the world isn't just personal.
It is personal but it's not just personal.
It's also relational.
Last week we saw in chapter 16 how hardship reveals the condition of our hearts.
And the same thing is true here.
That this includes our attitude towards other people.
You see when we grumble we want to blame our sinful responses on the hardship.
But the reality is, is it simply the hardships revealing what is already in our hearts.
So as Jesus put it, out of the abundance of the heart the mouth speaks.
So it's showing us the sinful broken condition of our hearts when that takes place.
It's like when you're cooking pasta and water starts to boil and it starts to kind of splash
out of the pan.
The heat wasn't the thing that put the water in there in the first place.
It's simply, it's revealing what is already there.
So when we go through the heat in our lives it's revealing what is in our hearts and
grumbling is demonstrating this internal distrust in the Lord's goodness or a resistance to
his reign.
Well if that's true of grumbling it's certainly true of quarreling as well.
So if you were to fall out with somebody and you were to be asked about that,
well what's the problem that leads to the conflict?
Well you might say, well that's easy, they're the problem.
Well how does James answer that question in James chapter four and verse one and two.
That question is posed.
It says, what causes quarrels and what causes fights among you?
Is it not this?
That's your desires are at war within you?
So the conflict is out here but he says here's the problem, the desires at war
within you, you desire and do not have so you murder, you covet and cannot get what
you want so you quarrel and fight.
So at its core conflict is an issue of the heart.
So we, if our selfish desires are not being met we're gonna dispute with others.
It's interesting, James in James four immediately then goes on to talk about prayer.
You see we should be committing our desires to the Lord in prayer asking him for what we need and
submitting to his will.
So our dependence should be upon him and ultimately our desires should be for him above all
else and it's God alone who can fully satisfy the longings of our hearts.
Another way of saying this is that if our contentment is rooted in something other than
Christ we will not be at rest.
So how does that play out relationally?
Well we can look to other people to provide what only God can give by satisfying the
desire of our hearts.
And but the truth is that no one can bear the burden of keeping you happy, making you content,
not your friends, not your spouse, not any children, not the church.
We cannot live under that burden.
If we look to others to fulfill that impossible task of making us content then that will
foster conflict because we will be let down time and time again because we're looking in the
wrong place, we're looking at people instead of the Lord.
Another way that this can play out relationally is that we can pursue contentment and other things.
Maybe a sense of significance or accomplishment at work or a desire for more leisure for some
comfort or it could be possessions chasing after that thing I'll be content once I have that.
Well what happens if somebody gets in your way of that, of you moving forward in your career or
getting the thing you want to have or in the way of you feeling the comfort you're wanting to feel?
Well then we'll be at war with that person once again because we're not looking to Christ for
contentment, we're looking to other things and we are at conflict with those who get in our way.
Instead we should be looking to Jesus and asking each day that we might grow in our dependence
upon him knowing that he satisfies the longings of our hearts. He's the one who gives rest to our
souls and he is the one who can transform our hearts so that we look upon one another with
graciousness and treat others the way that we have been treated by Christ.
So it's a place of quarreling. It's not just a place of quarreling, it's also a place of testing.
It's both called Mariba but also Massa, Massa. That means testing.
Chapter 16, we saw that the wilderness is a place of testing and that's a good thing because
God uses testing to teach us to trust and follow him. That's how the Lord transforms
us through testing. But here the tables have been turned and it's not a good thing
because it's people in turn testing the Lord. Instead of trusting the work that God is doing
in them, they want to force the Lord to shape the Lord to act as they want him to act,
to provide what they want when they want it. You see testing the Lord is something that
Scripture expressly forbids. As you go on to Deuteronomy chapter 6 and verse 16, it says this,
it says, you shall not put the Lord your God to the test. And it references back to here,
as you tested him at Massa. When Satan tempted Jesus in the wilderness, when he
tested him there, one of the things he tried to get Jesus to do was to go up
to the highest point of the temple and to jump off. And what did he say? He kind of
misapplied a Scripture saying, hey, the angels are going to bury you up. They're going to take
care of you. How did Jesus answer Satan with that test? He quoted Deuteronomy chapter 6 and verse 16,
you shall not put the Lord your God to the test. You see that kind of testing is trying to
force God's hand. And one way you can do that is by say putting yourself in harm's way.
Say, well, God is going to deliver me. I'm going to show you that he's present, that he's powerful.
I'm reading a book at the moment called Salvation on Sand Mountain. I shared it with some of you
guys earlier. And it's a book about, fascinating about snake handling churches. You know, I'm just
trying to get some ideas for Trinity. And I don't doubt the sincerity of the faith of those
believers that are taking up venomous serpents to prove God's presence and power among them.
But that crosses the line over into testing him. The thing is, the test that is going on in Exodus
17 is far worse. This isn't somebody would say misguided faith, trying to force God to prove
a miracle to show that he is present or that he is powerful by putting himself in harm's way.
Now, this is an angry and faithless mob demanding that God prove himself.
You know, I mentioned that quarreling oftentimes means to argue. Sometimes it can mean to fight,
but it's used actually a third way in Scripture. It's used for legal disputes,
like taking somebody to court. In other words, they are taking God to court here and how they
respond. So instead of humbling themselves before the Lord's greatness, they are attempting to
reverse that and stand in judgment over him. Now you might say, hang on a second,
look at the text. They're taking Moses to trial if they're taking anybody to trial.
That's true, but remember, Moses is representing the Lord. And it's made clear here that it is
the Lord that they are testing. Right? Verse 7 is because they tested the Lord, saying,
is the Lord here among us or not? So they are testing the Lord. So what's their accusation?
A one, well, God's not providing for them. If he were, they would have water.
Another accusation could be, well, God is not protecting us. You see, they go back to that
disparaging line about Moses, which they had used before about how he had led them out there just
to kill them off. You might say, this is an accusation of attempted homicide, leading them
out into the wilderness without enough water to drink. Another accusation is that, well,
God isn't even present with us. He's left us alone out here. You see that final summation
of their accusation is the Lord among us or not. What's the sentence that they want?
Remember, they're almost at the point of wanting the death penalty. When Moses prays,
he says, they're almost, they're about to take up stones to stone me.
Let's keep going with the courtroom language. What evidence do they bring?
Evidence do they bring? Now, if this were a fair trial, they could have had a mountain of undeniable
evidence that pointed to all the ways God had been faithful to them in the past.
You know, he redeemed them from slavery in Egypt. You know, he led them through the Red Sea. He
had only just miraculous who provided water and food for them in the wilderness each day
he was providing food for them. But instead of looking at that mountain of evidence,
all they present is their present thirst. So instead of looking to pass faithfulness,
all they're saying is, I'm thirsty now. If God is really my provider, where's the water?
If God is really protecting me, why does it feel like I'm about to die of dehydration? If God
is really here, why am I suffering? So God is on trial. That's not the last time God has been put on trial.
There's an interesting quote from C. S. Lewis, where he was making this observation in his day.
He said, the ancient man approached God as the accused person approaches his judge.
For the modern man, the roles are reversed. He is the judge. God is in the dock. He is quite a kindly
judge. If God should have a reasonable defense for being the God who permits war, poverty,
and disease, he's ready to listen to it. The trial may even end in God's acquittal.
But the important thing is, man is on the bench. God is in the dock.
You know, if we're honest with ourselves, it's not just our culture that does that. We can do the same
thing ourselves, even as believers. We do that when instead of looking at our present difficulties
in light of who God is, and all he's promised and all we've seen him do, we can sometimes reverse that.
We can look at who God is through the lens of our present difficulty.
We can keep our eyes on the hardship that we're facing and say, well, if I'm facing this hardship,
well, that must be who God is or what he's like or that fact that he's forsaken. We completely reverse it
instead of looking at circumstance in light of who God is. We look at who God is in light of
circumstances. Well, how does God respond? Well, instead of slamming down the gavel and giving them
the sentence they deserved as the ultimate judge, he allows himself to be tried, even provides for them.
So that brings us to the final word. We see this is a place of
meribun, it's a place of Massa, but it's also a place of mercy. It's a place of mercy.
You know, back in verse four, Moses asked the question, what shall I do with these people,
Lord? I wonder how you would have answered him. What would you do with them? Well, what was the Lord's
answer? What shall I do with them? I'm going to give them water to drink. You see, there's mercy
at the rock we read about. So they are led to this place what the Lord provides for them.
It's interesting, the kind of judicial language is still being used. So God instructs Moses to
take the elders with him. And so elders were sometimes gathered together to make decisions around
disputable claims that would be brought before the elders. So that's continuing on. And God instructs
Moses to take his staff with him. Remember that this is the staff that we've seen the Lord
use to execute judgment upon Egypt. In fact, in verse five, God references the time when this
very staff was used at the Nile River, turning it to blood. It was used in judgment to remove the
very source of life. God leads Moses with the staff and the elders to the rock at Horrib.
It says something mysterious and remarkable. It says that the Lord himself stood before them
on the rock. Do you see that? This is similar to the burning bush.
God in some mysterious way here is making himself present in a special way here at that rock. It
doesn't say whether or not this is visible, but he is there. And that makes the next part
all the more shocking. Hear this, feel the weight of this. God then instructs Moses to strike the rock
with the staff. So take this instrument of my judgment and strike the very place on which I stand.
Can you imagine how fearful a thing that was? I would imagine like, I don't know, throwing
something at a presidential motorcade. Like you're taking your life in your hands when you do that.
And here God is saying, I want you to strike this rock where my presence is. It's like God is here.
God himself is there standing in the place of the accused, even submitting himself
to the rod of his judgment. When that happens, water pours out from the rock.
Instead of God's people being struck down in judgment, the rock is struck and from it flows
a river of life, giving them exactly what they need. Life. God withheld the judgment that they
deserved and gave them a gift that they didn't deserve. Instead of enacting his justice,
he poured out his mercy. Of course, this rock was pointing us to a greater rock.
It's pointing to the mercy that God was going to show us in Christ.
1 Corinthians chapter 10, verses three and four says this. Hear this. It says,
our fathers ate the same spiritual food and all drank from the same spiritual drink.
For they drank from the spiritual rock. So this is pointing to the wilderness.
They drank from the spiritual rock. Well, what is this? The rock was Christ. Christ is the rock.
Well, how is Christ the rock? Well, he is God's very presence dwelling among us.
And though he did no wrong, he stood falsely accused. He underwent an unfair trial.
Then he was crucified. Well, what happened on the cross? Well, he was struck down in judgment so that
an undeserving people like you and me might be welcomed in mercy. And when he died, John gives us
this detail in John 1934. They checked to see if he had died by piercing his side and what flowed
out blood and water. This is, of course, a demonstration that he had truly died, but
it was also pointing to something else, because he is the water of life. He is God's provision for us.
God, are you going to provide? Yes, I provided for you in Jesus. He's the water of life.
You see, the people in the wilderness would drink that water, but they'd have to drink again
and again and again. But listen to what Jesus said to the woman at the well in John 4.
Whoever drinks of the water that I will give him will never be thirsty again. The water that I will
give him will become in him a spring of water welling up to eternal life. When we receive Christ by faith,
his spirit comes to dwell within us, his Holy Spirit gives us new life. And like a flowing river
that turns a desert into a garden, his life dwelling within us transforms us and brings us
into the life of flourishing that we were made for. So let's look to Christ as the water. It was
struck for us. He's the rock. He was struck for us. He's the water of life flowing for us.
So how do we respond as we look to Christ in that way? Let me just give you four quick responses.
One is drink. Come and drink from the water of life. Hear these words of Jesus in John 7.
If anyone thirsts, let him come to me and drink. That's an invitation for you and for me to know
Christ as the one who satisfies the longing of our souls, the one who gives us eternal life.
One time I just briefly went to a well dressing event in England not too far from where we were
living. And it's where the communities come together and they decorate local wells where
you know water is drawn from. And there was one well that was decorated that we went to go see.
And it was all about Charles Darwin. And it was just decorated beautifully. And right at the top
it had a quote as though it was from Darwin himself. And it said, if anyone thirsts,
let him come to me and drink. Not a very subtle statement they were making there.
Now don't mishear me. Science has been a means of bringing a lot of good into the world,
but it cannot save. It cannot satisfy the longing of our souls. Only Christ can do that.
And he invites all of us to come and freely drink from the water that he provides.
So drink. The other thing is remember, let's not be like the people in the wilderness.
Let's remember what God has done for us in Christ. And if he has done that for us,
how can we not trust him in any situation that we are in? Remember the ways he's provided for
you in the past that you might trust him in the present. Thirdly, pray. The people are crying
out. But notice where Moses is crying out. He's crying out to, but he's crying out to the Lord.
The Lord invites us to cry out to him. If you are in a dry season, we're always talking about
drinking from the water of life, doesn't feel like that to you. Seek the Lord.
Instead of running to the wells of the world that will leave you thirsty and unsatisfied
again and again. Come to the Lord and ask that he would supply all that you need, that he would be
to you what you need. Pray that he might bring you into deeper knowledge of himself.
Then the last way we need to respond is by then praising the Lord. Praise God for the
water of life. Our opening song had it right. Streams of mercy never ceasing. Call for songs
of loudest praise. Let's pray right now, shall we?
Lord, we thank you so much for the water of life that you have provided for us in Jesus.
Lord, I know that we have all experienced a feeling of thirst, dissatisfaction,
discontentment. But Lord, we thank you for the water of life. Lord, I pray that you would keep us
from always looking to the wells of this world instead of looking to Jesus. Lord, I pray that
you keep our eyes fixed upon him. Lord, I pray that we would hear your invitation even this
morning to come to you and drink. Lord, put your finger upon the areas of our lives where
we are looking to other things to satisfy rather than you. Lord, I pray that you would help us to
put our trust in you and to live from a place of trust and praise. We pray this in Jesus' name. Amen.